porque a nuestro territorio y ve
mencionaste heusser no me puedes decir
algo así no me digas eso jubilee media
presenta
[Música]
cuando vino todo esto del conflicto
entre palestina e israel creo que
cayeron estado profundo de tristeza
creo que no es justo que una nación que
es pacífica esté en esta situación donde
tienes que estar amenazada ser una chica
árabe viviendo en israel es bastante
difícil para mí principalmente en la
parte de mi identidad como ciudadana
como palestinos vivimos bajo ocupación
es decir que no tenemos ningún poder
creo que cada persona judío cristiano o
musulmán debe ser libre e igual bajo la
soberanía de israel
es necesario que se acabe este conflicto
entre nosotros pues no queremos que las
nuevas generaciones vivan esta vida que
hemos vivido hasta hoy
[Música]
si continuamos haciendo lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahora es probable que no
funcione y debemos hacer algo más
viajamos a jerusalén y trajimos a
palestinos e israelíes para discutir
juntos la actualidad y los conflictos
históricos de estas dos naciones y ver
si llegaban a un consenso mi nombre es
janashia te tengo 24 años y soy youtuber
árabe soy turista done tengo 25 años y
soy un accionista israelí judía me llamo
vara abdul soy de nablús tengo 25 años y
estudia relaciones públicas y
comunicaciones mi nombre es el ex hogar
vengo de un pequeño pueblo llamado givat
zeev a las afueras de jerusalén y tengo
24 años mi nombre es sarah tengo 24 años
y soy de jerusalén me llamo rahm maritza
fad tengo 34 años y trabajó como
supervisor de un grupo de expertos que
se ocupa de derecho y economía podrían
ponerse los israelíes a la izquierda y
los palestinos a la derecha por favor si
es
[Música]
ocho minutos para las personas cercanas
que han muerto gracias a este conflicto
mi padre fue asesinado por dos soldados
de la fed y fue algo muy doloroso para
mi familia somos todas mujeres y dentro
de la nación árabe eso es muy duro
cuando tenía diez años un francotirador
le disparó a mi mejor amiga en la cabeza
fue algo horrible para nosotros
yo crecí durante la segunda intifada
tengo una lista de
todos mis amigos que murieron en ataques
terroristas es una lista de 27 personas
que eran muy cercanas a mí en israel
tenemos un día de los caídos pues
siempre tengo un dilema sobre a qué
tumba visitar primero el 16 de enero de
2007 mi hermana abir fue asesinada por
un soldado israelí ella tenía 10 yo
tenía 13 éramos 6 niños en esa casa
después de eso fuimos dos hermanas y
tres hermanos
a todas las personas que conozco han
perdido a alguien en la guerra de alguna
manera creo que el duelo es
una emoción universal aquí de verdad
quisiera abrazar a cada uno de ustedes
ahora preste servicio en la fbi y sigo
en las reservas del ejército el combate
si es fuerte y más en la segunda
intifada yo siento su duelo y lo
entiendo pero debo decir que nunca
recibió órdenes de matar a nadie la
orden era disparar si alguien era una
amenaza para tu vida o para la de
alguien más
yo también preste servicio en la epe y
nos enseñaban a defendernos pero si no
lo hacíamos en defensa sino por
dispararle a otra persona íbamos a
prisión eso no es cierto
eso no es cierto déjame decirte algo el
soldado que mató a mi hermana lo pasó un
solo día los que mataron a mi padre esos
dos soldados jamás estuvieron en prisión
escenarios donde la solución es crear
dos estados
sí
muy bien pienso que los palestinos jamás
dejarán de decir que quieren un país
nosotros queremos un país entonces si el
punto es que podemos tener un estado
algo autónomo y ellos el suyo me parece
una solución sin problema alguno
creo que es mejor para todos si vivimos
juntos donde no hay un estado palestino
a un estado israelí estando juntos y
llevando la paz así no habría muro me
habría fronteras como las las hay ahora
estoy con ella un estado bajo la
soberanía de israel donde todos seamos
libres e iguales como ciudadanos porque
esperen bajo la soberanía israelí como
ahora que cuál es el problema porque
solo una religión toma el control qué
tal si hay más no es una religión es una
nacionalidad mi nacionalidad bueno y si
en ese estado que haremos los que
controlarán fueran los palestinos
tuberías bajo ese régimen no porque no
es tu territorio y bmw aceras puedes
decir oh eso no me digas eso solo sólo
estoy diciendo que un 100% preguntarte
algo sí por favor responde algo tu
abuelo su tatarabuelo sabes dónde está
si dónde está y cuántas generaciones
quieras y en siete de ellas siete bien
puedo contar las donde eso sería en
hungría en hungría siete generaciones y
seguimos en palestina no me digas que
este no es mi territorio
es tu territorio es nuestra tierra donde
los que veremos y permaneceremos como
determinas que no es su tierra pero si
es la nuestra
basado en qué historia leyes
internacionales intereses soberanía
bueno y qué tal la empatía tengo empatía
simplemente no estoy dispuesto a
renunciar a mi identidad a lo que creo
que me pertenece
me asusta ir al otro lado
cuando digo que me asusta me refiero a
que tengo miedo de ir a casa porque sé
que si llegara a acercarme a ese lugar
me dispararían alguien me matará creo
que dudé un poco en realidad no tengo
miedo de la gente del otro lado sino de
la brecha que existe entre nosotros casi
igualmente al miedo que tengo de que ese
lado asuma toda la responsabilidad de lo
que está sucediendo o que este lado se
haga cargo de todo me refiero a toda la
responsabilidad que es algo que no
funciona tampoco bueno creo que tienes
razón pienso que no todos los palestinos
son terroristas porque no tiene sentido
pero sí creo que quienes están a cargo
lideran a base del odio que nos tienen
sabes y de ese modo es realmente injusto
contrario a lo que estás diciendo ellos
no son el islam porque el islam no dice
maten maten personas liquiden las así no
es claro pero qué me dices de los
musulmanes radicales que realizan actos
terroristas que me dices de eso no son
parte de nosotros nunca hemos aceptado a
los musulmanes porque ellos enseñan a
odiar en parte entiendo lo que estás
diciendo hay un gran problema con
nuestros gobiernos porque no saben cómo
hablar entre ellos pienso enteramente
que los que van a cambiar eso somos
nosotros los ciudadanos estoy de acuerdo
no creo que el problema central sea los
musulmanes pero dijieron el hecho de los
territorios hay bastantes tratados de
paz se ha ofrecido el 97% del territorio
no hasta el 98 podría haber funcionado
no me parecido después de firmar esos
tratados construyeron nuevas colonias en
esos territorios qué hay de malo con los
judíos que viven me juré no hay nada de
malo en eso el problema es que ya se
había hablado sobre estas tierras que le
pertenecían a ellos y al final los
israelíes vinieron y construyeron sus
casas allí eso demuestra que no quieren
paz
yo confío en mis fuentes de información
sobre el conflicto
este servicio en live así que confío en
mí y en mis oficiales sé que la mayoría
de la información que obtenemos no es
precisa por lo que todo lo comparo de
diferentes fuentes me gusta pedir
opinión de otras personas sobre esto
para saber qué es lo que piensan
no confío en lo que dicen en las
noticias de seguro de verdad pienso que
hay dos lados de cada historia pero
puedo ver las cosas que están sucediendo
a mi alrededor cosas como los bombardeos
ataques y asesinatos son cosas en las
que puedo evidenciar lo que pasa porque
lo estoy bien puedo ver
la narrativa que se quiere establecer es
como que veo la televisión y sé lo
importante e influyente que es el
lenguaje cómo puede crear realidades
cuando veo estas cosas puedo evidenciar
que es peligroso para ambos lados es
realmente peligro los medios de
comunicación extranjeros que veo siempre
están en contra de israel por cosas que
no son culpa nuestra me parece divertido
porque como yo lo veo el mundo está de
parte de israel- es divertido
por eso me parece gracioso pero en serio
creo que la información que obtenemos
tiene como agenda oculta proveniente de
ambos lados no creo en las redes
sociales porque desde el lado israelí
van a apoyar a israel y del lado
palestino a palestina eso hace todo
realmente confuso y nos hará
distorsionar la realidad digamos que las
dudas provienen de las fuentes pero no
sólo deben ser informes de redes
sociales o de medios de comunicación yo
confío plenamente en los informes que
publica la fuerza de seguridad israelí
no confíes anuncios ni idea
no se basan en la realidad o la
situación pero son ideas personales de
cómo ver la situación pero realmente no
es lo que sucede
quiero líderes políticos que se
comprometan a hacer la paz
efe
si continuamos haciendo las cosas como
hasta ahora no podremos ver nada mejor a
futuro y nuestros líderes deberían estar
más interesados en nuestras vidas y lo
mejor para todos nosotros no es
compromiso porque la paz nunca llegará
por un compromiso los políticos
palestinos quieren la paz para para
ellos mismos y para el pueblo pero ellos
no tienen poder para decidir eso ya que
eso no está en sus manos el poder está
del otro lado
se podría hablar de compromisos y
ustedes también estuviesen dispuestos a
comprometerse porque no tiene sentido
que cada vez que se empieza una guerra
ustedes siempre dan el primer golpe hace
día se escuche de 1800 acres de cultivo
que fueron quemados por los ataques de
hamas un ataque que se mandó sobre
israel en lugar de gastar todo ese
dinero tratando de arruinarnos porque no
lo usan para algo mejor como cuidar a su
gente vamos a hablar
estás hablando de hamás y también de gas
gas está muy lejos de nosotros la verdad
es que no sabemos qué sucede y no
tenemos idea si tú me preguntarás sobre
sobre westbank yo te respondería pero yo
sé que usted es así es como yo lo veo se
habla de compromiso pero el cartel jamás
ha dicho que matarían a un judío donde
quiera que esté y las autoridades no
espera espera esperan los moderadores
hay hablando acerca de hamás pero las
llevamos hablando acerca legal yo
palestinos déjame terminar son los
moderadores de esto dicen que si le
vendes tu casa un judío es una sentencia
de muerte y racistas en israel claro y
en el mundo muchos más pero
lo que condenamos son los actos
violentos que se usan para glorificar
una gestión de gobierno
la violencia es justificada en ocasiones
no lo sé
si tú atacas a israel pues israel tiene
que defenderse me refiero a que si
suceden cosas como esas quizás no con
ustedes específicamente pero sí con los
musulmanes radicales que hay porque si
no lo hacemos no habría un estado de
israel'
no creo que sea una cuestión de
israelíes judíos musulmanes o cristianos
a veces debes usar la violencia espero
estar lo más alejado de ese entorno pero
si veo a alguien atentando contra la
vida de otra persona está bien usar la
violencia para defenderte pero no creo
que la violencia se pueda ver como un
logro político no es un buen lugar para
usarla yo prefiero hablar y tener un
discurso bien yo no crecí en un entorno
violento no fue así eso era casi nulo
pero eso es lo que ustedes dicen
si alguien irrumpe en mi casa rompe la
puerta y atacan a mi padre por supuesto
que responderé me defenderé es violencia
pero claro que tengo que defenderme ante
todo estoy en contra de la violencia en
un 100% es un círculo vicioso que se
repite una y otra vez para mí si
respondes a la violencia con más
violencia no hay solución tendríamos los
mismos problemas la misma generación que
está creciendo con odio y violencia
hambre de sangre y eso no está bien
tener una patria es importante para mi
gente y para mí
creo que israel tiene que ser nuestra
patria porque si no tenemos una nadie
más nos aceptará
especialmente porque hay mucho racismo y
antisemitismo en el mundo si no tenemos
a dónde ir qué podríamos hacer bueno
para mí como musulmán esa es mi tierra
santa y por eso es tan importante ante
todo porque nací allí y no tengo otro
lado no hay otro lugar todas las
personas en el mundo tienen derecho a
vivir en el lugar donde nacieron y para
los palestinos si hablamos de los que
están refugiados creo que tienen el
derecho de volver aquí a su tierra a sus
casas y a sus propiedades el hecho de
que podamos volver a nuestra tierra y
que tengamos un lugar donde llegar un
gobierno con el que podamos contar se
siente como un milagro
pero pienso que el poder conlleva una
gran responsabilidad y no podemos
arraigar nos al hecho de que es mi
tierra y no escucharé las opiniones ni
pensamientos de otros porque eso es lo
que nos ha traído hasta aquí
a menudo cuestiono mi lugar en este
conflicto
todo el tiempo me pregunto si las redes
sociales la fuerza y los diálogos van a
mejorar esto y pienso cuál es la mejor
solución lo único que puedo pensar es en
la interacción humana muchas veces me
tomo el tiempo para aplazar mis
argumentos políticos sobre este
conflicto y todo esto solo porque pienso
que nadie sabe lo suficiente como para
opinar sobre esto
en mi caso siempre he sabido que estoy
inmersa en este conflicto siempre supe
que debía pelear por la paz eso es todo
lo que yo sé y nunca tuve esa idea hasta
que mi padre fue asesinado y tuve que
cuidar de mí misma siempre le preguntaba
a mi padre
porque había nacido
y él siempre me respondía no para matar
sino para vivir
para tener vida y cuando mi hermana fue
asesinada
le hice esa misma pregunta de nuevo y su
respuesta fue la misma pero mi hermana
ella sí nació para morir
los palestinos ellos no mataron a seis
millones de judíos y los israelíes no
han matado a seis millones de palestinos
entonces porque hay una embajada alemana
en tel aviv y también hay una embajada
israelí en alemania
es una cosa muy loca es una idea
esperanza de que algún día todo esto se
puede resolver y podamos me gusta mucho
me gusta mucho esa idea pero no creo que
ese sea el caso israel hizo la paz con
egipto porque ellos estaban dispuestos a
hacer las paces con israel israel hizo
lo mismo con jordania porque ellos
estuvieron dispuestos a hacer la sky sí
es cierto pero no todas las posiciones
son iguales ustedes creo nada que pueda
haber una paz entre los dos estados
porque como yo lo entiendo el concepto
entero de la nacionalidad palestina
porque ustedes no aceptan a los
palestinos acepto a los seres humanos lo
que quiero decir es que todo el concepto
de la nacionalidad palestina es la
aniquilación de israel
cuando jordania tomó judea y samaria
cuando egipto tomó gas a nadie preguntó
pero estás combinando demasiadas
personas en una sola ideología y eso no
está bien dices que por el hecho de ser
palestinos eso es lo que quieren y no
eso si es cierto me retracto quise decir
el gobierno de palestinos y los
instintos individuales de acuerdo es
diferente
es decir eso no me refiero a los árabes
palestinos me refiero a ellos como
árabes de judea y samaria si llegamos a
vivir muchos
muchos años espero que si nos veremos
nos veremos unos a otros
genial bienvenidos a miremos ahora algo
algo así lo lograremos lo vamos a lograr
como palestinos y podrán tener no me
refiero a la paz tendremos paz como
ellos
me gustaría sentarme y tener un
compartir con todas las personas de esta
sala
[Risas]
[Música]
y mire eso gracias
se ve delicias hola gracias hola chicos
cómo están
soy yo ni hola cariño mi nombre
salam alaykum en la punta tiene un poco
de parchita y su jugo en lo que le da
ese toque especial y delicioso
[Risas]
entonces qué les pareció chicas perfecta
muy buena
fue una excelente reunión fue un poco
turbia al principio porque realmente
como dije
no sabes que en está frente a ti no
conoce sus ideas su ideología y lo que
piensan sobre ti creo que llegamos a un
tipo de acuerdo ya que ambos queremos la
paz
seguridad libertad y prosperidad para
todos hablas de acuerdos legales no
quiero un papel que diga paz quiero
vivir en paz no quiero más papeles ya
tenemos muchos de esos pero pero no
estamos de acuerdo en que yo no creo en
un estado palestino y ustedes quieren la
división de los estados allí no estamos
bien no pero algunos queremos la
solución de un solo estado israel todos
iguales y libres finalizó exactamente
bueno aprendí de ti que también sientes
mucha simpatía por nuestro lado aunque
tu hermana falleció lo cual es terrible
ella no falleció fue asesinada pero
puedo ver que también tiene simpatía por
el otro lado y en realidad estás
tratando de comunicarte con nosotros a
pesar de todo lo que has pasado
definitivamente aprendí que también
podemos aprender a amar tu lado o
podríamos aprender algún día
creo que este es el punto principal de
nuestro conflicto que no nos escuchamos
el uno al otro
así que creo que es importante
escucharse unos a otros no solo mantener
los pensamientos e ideas en la cabeza
sino de entender al otro queremos cosas
realmente similares
es como si los conociera desde antes
sabes como amigos y entonces darnos
cuenta de que tenemos el mismo tipo de
lenguaje y no en el lenguaje que
hablamos sino en nuestro lenguaje
corporal las cosas que nos interesan y
el futuro que tenemos para nosotros y
nuestras familias no hay lados no puedo
trazar una línea y decir que está bien
no se puede separar por lados
hola chicos soy jayson y yo soy john
sólo queríamos agradecerles por ver un
episodio realmente especial de middle
ground nos encanta esta serie porque es
una oportunidad y ahora más que nunca
para crear un gran diálogo y una empatía
radical fue un desafío pero también un
privilegio poder ir a jerusalén a filmar
este diálogo en torno a un tema que es
muy delicado y muy difícil pero nos
encantó totalmente jubilee vive
intensamente